a given River and tributary system exist
as described in the table previous
studies conducted Downstream of where
these two sources mix have determined
that negative impacts to Aquatic Life
occur when dissolved oxygen drops below
5 migs per liter due to a proposed dam
being considered Upstream of the mixing
point the flow of the river is expected
to be reduced in the future by how much
can the flow be reduced if at all in CFS
without causing adverse impacts to
Aquatic Life Downstream of the mixing
point so we have a given River and
tributary system existing as described
in this table here the way the problem
is describing it is we have the river
here and a
tributary here and the downstream mixing
point would be somewhere around here
after those two sources come together
so this problem is a pretty basic
example of a mass balance problem that
you would find in an undergraduate
environmental engineering class I don't
think there's an equation for it in the
reference manual the closest I found was
on page 460 if you want to see an
example of what a mass balance equation
for a slightly different application
might look like the version of the mass
balance equation that we want to use can
instead be written as follows q1
C1 plus Q2 C2
equals
Q3
C3 where Q3 is going to be a combination
of q1 plus
Q2 so let's begin the problem is asking
us to find how much flow in the river
can be reduced Upstream of the river and
tributary mixing point before the
section of the river Downstream of the
mixing Point drops below 5 mg per liter
of dissolved oxygen so they want to know
how much can change up here such that
down here doesn't drop below a certain
point so step one is going to be to find
the current concentration in the river
and tributary Downstream of the mixing
point so let's write this
out in this case q1 we're going to say
is the river
so
85 fet cubed per second times the
concentration of
6 millgram per liter
plus
25 cubic feet per second from the
tributary times 3 MGR per
liter equals the sum of these two
together is going to be 110 cubic feet
per second times whatever the
concentration currently is Downstream
and solving for this we can find that C3
is going to be just about
5.32 milligram per
liter so as we can see 5.32 is going to
be greater than the current standard so
the way the question is asking
us the river can drop by some amount of
flow Upstream here before the downstream
mixing Point goes from 5.32 to 5 so our
answer of zero is already crossed
[Music]
off now step two is going to be to set
the C3 term at 5 milligram per liter and
then calculate backwards for what q1
would need to be in order to achieve
this lower concentration limit so let's
do that
now now we're going to say
q1 cubic feet per
second times 6
milligrams per liter plus
25 cubic feet per
second * 3 mg per liter equals we have
to solve for q1 still
plus
25 cubic
feet per second and our lower limit here
as we just described is going to be set
at 5 mg per
liter so solving this out we're going to
get 6 q1 I'm going to ignore units for
Simplicity sake here + 75 =
q1 plus
125 and simplifying this out we will get
q1
equals
50 cubic feet per
second so finally the question is
phrased by how much can the flow be
reduced so we simply need to subtract
the new flow from the old flow to find
the difference so step three is very
simple it's going to be
q1 old minus
q1
new or in this case 85 minus
50 cubic feet per second will give us an
answer of 35 cubic feet per second we
can see that answer is number two over
here and the problem is
solved so this problem is a simple mass
balance problem that needs to be
calculated twice the real trick here is
just reading the problem carefully to
understand what is being asked for
otherwise we might select the wrong
answer from a different term that we'
have already calculated for
such as 50 this problem also gives you
an option to for the answer you would
get if you only divide the
river by the difference in
concentrations as well so if you divided
5.32 by 5 and then divided the flow of
85 by that percent you would get
something closer to
76.5 but again we're looking for q1 and
the difference in these calculations is
at the mixing point in
Q3 so avoid those tricks by knowing
where your locations of q1 Q2 and Q3 are
and you should be fine and that's it